let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
okay so starting here uh dr fauci was on
cnn yesterday and and he wanted to make
sure to
throw some cold water on any embers of
hope
that anyone might have you can't have
any hope no hope is allowed
so here's how that went now you've
already encouraged americans to consider
canceling any thanksgiving plans that
involve
visiting with somebody else or having
visitors come
i know a lot of americans are looking
ahead hoping to make plans for other
holidays such as christmas
but when do you think americans will
next be able to
safely gather together uh for family
events like this are you suggesting it
probably won't be able to happen until
i don't know labor day 2021 thanksgiving
2021.
now if i could just jump in here for a
second jake if i could briefly
and i know you weren't asking me the
question but i'm going to answer it
anyway
let me say that americans can gather
with their families right now
uh there's no need to wait until labor
day
or you know christmas 2021 i've been
gathering with my family
ever since this all began we had a big
family reunion in in
june i hate to admit it um
i don't know i don't know if the fed's
gonna be busting out down my door now
but that's that's what we did
we've gotten together plenty since then
we've had some kids birthdays and
other events everybody was fine nobody
got sick
nobody died uh nobody even had a case of
the sniffles afterwards
so my point is you can get together now
if you want to take charge of your own
life make your own decisions
uh be an adult be an american you could
do that
so that's my response to that but here's
fouchy's response
you know it depends on a number of
factors jake for example
we have vaccines now the first one that
came out was highly effective
i anticipate that the second one likely
will be comparable
you never can tell until you see the
data but would be comparable
that's great but we have to get people
to take the vaccine
so if we get the overwhelming majority
of people taking the vaccine and you
have on the one hand
an effective vaccine on the other hand a
high degree
of uptake of the vaccine we could start
getting things back to
relative normal as we get into the
second and third quarter of the year
where people can start thinking about
doing things that were too dangerous
just months ago
but we've got to put all those things
together jake we can't just wish it
happening we've got to get the vaccine
it's got to be deployed and we
can't abandon fundamental public health
measures
you can approach a degree of normality
while still doing some fundamental
public health things
that synergize with the vaccine to get
us back to normal
so not until the second or third quarter
of 2021 though
christmas is probably not going to be
possible yeah i'm okay so we have two
things there first of all we have a
christmas is not going to be possible
from jake tapper and and the thing is he
he said that yesterday
and that this clip went went viral on
twitter
uh with people accusing jake tapper of
saying that essentially we have to
cancel christmas or at least with our
families you can't get together with
chris
for christmas with your families and the
spin from
uh people trying to defend jake tapper
is that no no he didn't he didn't say
that he was
what he was trying to say is that um
it's not gonna be possible to have a
vaccine by christmas well no you heard
it right there that's not what he was
saying
he said christmas is not gonna be
possible can't we can't do christmas
that's what he said it was right there
in the clip you heard it for yourself
uh but again jake tapper doesn't get to
cancel christmas
dr fouch doesn't get to cancel it the
governor of your state wherever you live
cannot cancel it they can try and they
are trying
but they can't actually do it
what needs to happen here is we we call
their bluff
and i think that's what people should
have been doing all along but especially
when it comes to these limits on the
numbers of people you can have
in your own home for thanksgiving or
christmas or just in general
call their bluff go ahead if you live up
in new york
you know you have as many people as you
want over for thanksgiving if if
if andrew cuomo really wants to send
police
busting down your door to cart your
in-laws away
which part of that frankly seems a
little bit appealing but
if he really wants to do that you know
maybe it's kind of a win-win uh you know
on one side your in-laws get arrested on
the other side of it as well uh
you know i maybe that will be the thing
that finally wakes up the american
population i don't know
so we have that we also have fauci
saying that
even with the vaccine we still are going
to have to
uh have masks and social distancing and
all these all these
so-called protective measures so let's
follow the trajectory here
with the masks first they said if
if we try to remember in our heads
originally they said don't wear a mask
no remember they didn't just say don't
wear a mask
they said essentially if you wear a mask
you're a [ __ ] remember those tweets
from the surgeon general
screaming at people seriously stop
wearing masks you morons
you didn't say morons but that was the
tone of it so originally was don't wear
a mask
and then it was well probably you should
wear a mask when you're out in public
um you know uh or you know if you're if
you're if you're out of the store or
something there's strangers around
probably you should wear a mask
and then it was probably you should wear
a mask outside too
and then it was you should just wear
masks all the time
and now they're saying uh yeah you
should wear masks even with your when
you're with your own family for
thanksgiving
and oh yeah we should probably actually
wear masks even after the vaccine
and we're just gonna wear masks forever
pretty soon it'll be
after you die you wear a mask in the
grave because you can never be too
careful
uh number two staying on this on this
theme here washington state
is going into full lockdown again in
fact a number of states are
this this was the most recent one
announced this in michigan
so here's the governor of washington
introducing the rehashed
measures that didn't work the first time
so let's try them again
so the restrictions we're announcing
today which will be in effect through
december 14th
are not as comprehensive or some degree
tough as our stay home order in march
but every part of our state will see
robots in some sense
most will take effect at midnight monday
this is not forever this is only for now
thanks to the brilliance of our medical
community a vaccine is on the way
we need to hold this pandemic down until
the cavalry arrives
this is a temporary situation in our
state where we seek a permanent healthy
condition
and our goal is to keep the most people
alive as possible until the vaccine and
other therapeutic measures arrives
and that's a task i believe washington
is up to
so here are some parts of our plan
indoor social gatherings with people
from outside
your home are prohibited unless they
quarantine for 14 days prior to the
social gathering
or quarantine for the seven days prior
to the gathering
and receive a negative coven 19 test
result
no more than 48 hours prior to the
gathering and they've got a they
released a whole list of of what the
restrictions are
and um i'm looking at it right here
uh just it's a it's a lengthy list
indoor social gatherings uh with people
from outside your household are
prohibited
unless they quarantine for 14 days
um so they're they're saying it doesn't
there's not even a limit it's just you
can't you can't do it period
unless they quarantine for for 14 days
beforehand
um outdoor social gatherings shall be
limited to five people from outside your
household
restaurants and bars are closed for
indoor dining service
because you know these these governors
they didn't succeed in completely
killing their economies and
and completely destroying i mean they
decimated the restaurant
industry but they didn't completely
destroy it now they're going back around
for the kill shot
that's what's happening here um gyms and
fitness facilities are closed
um movie theaters are closed
this is the kind of thing this this is
just just completely egregious
and and flagrant move why close movie
theaters there's just no reason to close
them
you could very easily socially distance
in a movie there
a movie theater would be one of the
easiest things to keep open
because you can easily control the
number of people who come in you spread
them out
no problem you'll be very easy to do
they close bowling alleys bowling alleys
are closed again no reason for that
to be extremely just spread out i mean
when's the last time you've been in a
bowling alley that was completely packed
anyway
maybe have people wear their own shoes
in case you're wondering about covet on
the shoes i don't know
there's there's just so many really
basic things we could do
without shutting down these industries
but these governors almost all of them
democrats are saying yeah forget that
we'll just we'll just destroy the
industry why not
uh number three a report here from the
blaze says actress melissa mccarthy
known for her roles in comedic films
caved to the outrage mob last week after
she was attacked online for donating
money to an organization dedicated to
ending human sex trafficking
so she's apologizing for giving money to
a charity
against human sacrificing all right um
so the she's uh part of a promotion for
the new movie super intelligence
mccarthy teamed up with hbo max for 20
days of kindness
which is a campaign donating 20 donating
20 000 to 20 different charities
over the course of 20 days so far so
good
included on the list was exodus cry
which is a non-profit organization
dedicated to eradicating
sex trafficking um but the daily beast
got wind of this and they did a hit
piece on exodus cry
and here's what they said it's from the
daily beast
the daily beasts tarpley hit exclusively
reported on thursday that exodus cry
frames itself as an anti-sex trafficking
group but in reality works to abolish
sex work entirely
oh the horror its founder benjamin noah
has called abortion a holocaust and
homosexuality an unspeakable offense to
god
the group has spent years lobbying to
criminalize the purchase of sex and uh
recently launched campaign to shutter
pornhub
that sounds like a great this is the
first time i've heard of accidents crap
but i'll tell you right now i'm going to
be donating to them
i'm going to make a handsome donation
exodus cry sound great to me
uh so that's the great offense though
they they not only try to rescue women
from sex
trafficking but they also oppose the
industries
that depend on sex trafficking and that
drive sex trafficking
so they want to bail the water out of
the boat and
plug the leak well that's that's
horrible that's bigoted
it's better to keep bailing the titanic
out
with little mop buckets and thimbles
while leaving the iceberg
size gash in the hull because that's
that's on the left when they talk about
battling sex trafficking
that's what they want to do because as
far as the industries that keep this
going that depend on it fund it push it
um fuel it they don't do anything with
those industries
and so melissa mccarthy anyway brave
woman that she is um
she got a little bit of a push back and
uh and decided to
take the money back and she issued this
groveling apology
hi there um it has come to our attention
that our 20 days of kindness
which is something a kindness hub that
we started to kind of shed the light on
20 great charities
had one um in there that there's no
other way to say it
we blew it we made a mistake and we
backed a charity
that upon proper vetting stands for
everything that we do not
um so i want to thank everyone on social
media who said
what are you doing are you sure you want
to back this because the answer is
no we do not we have pulled it
we are so incredibly grateful for you
ringing the bell and
helping us be better we're sorry for our
mistake
oh boy are we sorry for it can't believe
that we missed it
um and that's it and i just uh
i want to say hope it doesn't ding the
other charities because they're really
doing some amazing things and 20 days of
kindness
uh is really meant to shine the light on
all of those wonderful charities so
let the kindness continue and uh thank
you
thanks for the help we really needed it
just a picture of courage there that
melissa mccarthy isn't she
i mean just think about this you
she could have easily ignored this
she could have taken that route just
ignore it it'll go away people aren't
people aren't that focused on it or she
could have done the right thing and come
out and said
hey listen this is a good organization
they're fighting sex trafficking
i don't agree with all their views but
but they're doing they're doing an
important service
and um and you know if they're again if
they're against pornhub
while at the same time saving women from
sex trafficking that's a trait i'm
willing to make
she could have done that and she she
risks nothing
but nothing speaking of putting nothing
on the line having no stakes what what
you know if she were to stand up against
the outrage mob
what happens to her what's the worst
case scenario
that her super intelligence movie flops
it was gonna flop anyway
all of her movies flop um but she's
still a multi-millionaire she'll still
get work
so that's that's why it can be so
demoralizing when you see these
people on the on the public stage who
are massively wealthy
and they've got so many fans and
everything and they cave so quickly to
the outrage mob
because for them it should be the
easiest to stand against it think about
drew brees another another perfect
example
you know deciding he for a moment he
stood up for
the ant literally for the anthem and for
police got a little bit of push back and
said oh never mind i'm sorry i'm sorry
for supporting the flag
and supporting police uh you're right i
you know what i am going to take the
side of of of you know convicted
criminals and and uh
instead instead of the police but what
was the worst case scenario for him if
he stood up against the outrage mob
what happens to him even if he gets cut
from the team which was never going to
happen because he's drew brees
for god's sake but even if he did he's
still still rich and wealthy still still
set for life he can do whatever he wants
but if these people who have everything
won't stand up when they when they
really risk nothing if they won't stand
up against it
what about people who don't have that
kind of security that's why it's so
demoralizing okay let's go to number
four this is
from the daily wire it says not content
to ban smoking in public san francisco
is now considering a ban
on smoking in one's own home should they
live in an apartment
reason reported that the city's board of
supervisors are considering the bill and
voted last thursday to advance it
the bill would ban smoking inside
private dwellings located in apartments
with three or more units according to
the outlet
the bill wouldn't apply to just tobacco
products with known secondhand concerns
it would also ban marijuana and even
vaping in the private dwellings
the san francisco examiner reported
saying the bill sponsored
bill sponsor supervisor um norman yay
said in a tweet that the goal of the
bill was to help residents avoid being
exposed to second-hand smoke in their
own homes
he says smoke easily moves between units
and buildings
now that more of us work from home it's
more important than ever because there
is no way to contain it
by the way there's no evidence
whatsoever
that if your neighbor smokes it's
somehow going to give you cancer
no evidence of that there just isn't um
[Music]
but i think it's not a coincidence here
i don't see this as a coincidence that
on one hand you've got these coveted
restrictions
and state governments assuming they have
the right and the power to tell you how
many people
you can have in your own home and now
you've got a smoking ban
in private residences you know it's
we're setting a precedent with the cove
restrictions
and it's not going to be contained just
to that i think we've already seen that
and the precedent is the government can
tell you what you can do in your own
home
um and this is there
there are going to be consequences to
that we have seen this over and over
again with with the government i mean
throughout human history when you give
the government when you
submit to that to the government and
give it a certain power
it's not just going to give it back and
and always it always it always well
we need the power just an emergency
situation here we just need it for now
give us this power and we but we'll give
it up once once the emergency passes
and time and time again of course the
public says well okay if you say so
you never lied to us before except every
other time
so that's the way this is going to go
number five finally
um if if joe biden is going to be
president then
i think we found the anthem for the next
four years
this i think um i think we could say at
least this is
the best pro-biden song ever written
though of course the bar is so low that
it's you know somewhere now down near
the core of the earth
at this point but anyway uh here's the
song listen
i can't believe it
all my dreams came true
[Music]
america voted and the country turned
blue
[Music]
we wanted joe biden
for the next four years
we wanted kamala
[Music]
and now there's no need to fear
and who's commander isn't she
the one that trump can't defeat
[Music]
yeah the second-hand embarrassment is so
intense
watching that that you feel like you're
suffering actual physical trauma
while you watch it and i i just i i
what i'm wondering is whose idea
was that i assume it was the guy's idea
because he's the lead singer so the guy
went up to his girlfriend or his wife or
whoever
maybe his uber passenger i don't know
and said hey babe
i wrote this uh this sexy joe biden song
what do you say we hop in the front seat
and sing it together
and the crazy thing is that she said yes
to that
maybe she didn't ask to hear it ahead of
time that's what i'm thinking so she's
sitting there
listening and experiencing the same
horror we are
but she's on camera she can't show it
the show must go on
suddenly this has become a story of
great courage and selflessness
on the part of the woman and that's
that's how i choose to see it
in an inspiring way well i hope you
enjoyed that clip from the matt walsh
show if you did go ahead and hit
that subscribe button right down there
so you can stay up to date on all of our
future content